some interesting news about planned
parenthood so life site news has this
and you you hopefully know that planned
parenthood
is the number one abortion conglomerate
in america
uh number one abortion provider as they
would call themselves
they slaughter over 300 000 children
every single year
um you know they are
they have they have killed millions and
millions of people
of human beings babies this obviously is
their number one priority
is abortion that's how they make most of
their money you know you want to
you you look at where they make their
income
and it's abortion and tax money
that's that's that's where it all that's
where almost all of it comes from
um now planned parenthood in public will
say that's not the case
and planned parenthood's defenders will
often say things like oh
abortion is only three percent of what
they do i'm sure you've heard that
figure before
three percent it's only three percent of
their business that's all
trying to make it sound like it's it's
certainly not the main focus it doesn't
even really matter that much
you could take abortion away it would
have have almost no impact on the
on the institution at all which already
is sort of interesting because
if it's that if it's if it's that
small and if it hardly matters then why
does planned parenthood
defend it as viciously as they do but we
know that the three percent figure is
total nonsense the way that they get to
that number
and as always you know this is how you
can lie with a statistic
the way they get to that number is by
unbundling what they would call
unbundling their services
and then and then sort of weighting all
of the services the same
so um you know an analogy would be
something like
maybe a a car dealership if they were to
sell
three cars and then also sell
100 water bottles from their vending
machine then then and then they turn
around and say well
selling cars is only three percent of
what we do but really we're a water
bottle distributor
primarily but
when you when you look at where they
make their money it's in selling cars
not water bottles
and so there's a bunch of other things
that planned parenthood does
in theory you go there you could get um
birth control for example there are
there are other services they provide
and they may even provide those services
like something like giving away free
birth control easy enough to do that's a
really easy service to provide
they may provide those services more
often than they perform abortions
but abortion is the central piece of
their business
and of all the services they provide
that's where they make the lion's share
of their income
okay that's the reality but many people
are confused on this point
including the former president of
planned parenthood herself
so here's what lifesitenews reports they
say in her memoir published on july
27th dr liana wen details her time spent
as president of the nation's largest
abortion provider planned parenthood
gwen offers readers an insider's view of
the organization's obsession with
abortion
in lifeline a doctor's journey in the
fight for public health
among other things she says that she was
told to say abortion in
every media interview someone also
warned her that
if we don't talk about abortion openly
loudly and proudly as a positive moral
good
then we're further stigmatizing it
served as president for eight short
months before planned parenthood
suddenly ended her employment during a
secret meeting in 2019
um at the time she'd share she said that
she left because of philosophical
differences now she's written this sort
of this expose
um talking about what really happened
behind the scenes
uh it says as she reveals in her book
when faced opposition from planned
parenthood from the very beginning of
how
because of how she handled abortion
uh quote one of the main points i wanted
to get across was that health care
shouldn't be political she remembered
from when she
prepared for her first media appearance
as president on abc's the view
i'd come to this job as a doctor and my
charge was patients lives
her message was met with applause and
cheering from the show's audience she
said but not from
planned parenthood less than an hour
after the messages started coming some
of which threw her off guard
first a board member texted her saying
next time make sure you talk about
abortion
then someone else said then two people
on the national staff informed her that
back in the office there was a lot of
worried chatter
did i leave out abortion on purpose they
wondered wen said was this a signal that
i didn't want to defend access to
abortion
um one of them also advised her to next
time just say the word
the unnamed person added you need to
talk about abortion at every media
interview
you're the president of planned
parenthood people expect that from you
this caused when to reevaluate planned
parenthood and she says until that
moment
i thought the overriding reason planned
parenthood was equated with abortion
instead of its other health care
services
was the anti-choice opposition i was
taken aback to see that it wasn't just
the anti-choice side that wanted to bet
to brand planned parenthood
with abortion this is really
kind of amazing you you've got
a woman who was uh
the president of planned parenthood
only for eight months which is she's a
medical she's doctor
medical professional grown adult
obviously familiar with these issues
becomes the president of planned
parenthood and she was shocked to
discover
that planned parenthood cares only about
abortion
this is what she talks about in the book
anytime she was in front of the media
all they wanted her to do was talk about
abortion
this this came as a surprise to her
now i have never stepped foot inside of
a planned parenthood and never would
i could have told you that clearly this
is what they do
this is where they make their money this
is what they care about
it just shows you how thoroughly uh
people have been deluded
and how successful planned parenthood
has been and you know let's not give
them too much credit
uh it's easy to be successful with this
when you have the entire media on your
side when the entire media is a
propaganda
organ for you um
then it's easy to be successful in
diluting the public
into thinking that you're primarily a
health care clinic
and you know you do abortions on the
side here and there
yes you will you will viciously defend
abortion
at every step
you will not allow any criticism about
or any questions about it
but it's not that big of a deal
this is how diluted people are um
and they have to be you know the planned
parenthood needs people to be deluded
in this way because if you actually
began to see planned parenthood for what
it is
and you really stopped to think about
this
this is a company that has made billions
of dollars from
killing people and they kill
300 000 humans every year
when you when you stop and think about
that you know it's it's kind of hard to
just drive
by them on your way to work and see them
in some
shopping mall and say oh it's planned
parenthood just like any other
business well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt well show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content